[Musique]
le collège antoine soubou rentrer dans
le réseau des écoles associées à
l'unesco
créé en 1953 ce réseau contient plus de
11500 établissements scolaires répartis
dans 182 pays qui travaillent en faveur
d'une éducation de qualité
c'est ce que nous rappelle madame mais
la principale du collège soubou les
projets ont amené cette inscription sont
de diverses natures mais principalement
celui du langtang qui a permis de donner
un coup de projecteur à tout ce qui est
réalisé au quotidien dans le collège
donc ça n'est pas une action
exceptionnelle qui fait cette entrée
mais c'est une action exceptionnelle qui
permet l'entrée et c'est au quotidien
que l'on continuera à faire vivre toutes
les valeurs qui sont promus par l'unesco
et le souhaitions que obtenir cette
labellisation pour que ces valeurs
soient bien ancrée et les écoles
associées vise à mieux préparer les
élèves à relever les défis d'un monde le
département soutient et favorise la
réussite en faveur des collégiens
le collège antoine soubou fait partie
maintenance du réseau des écoles
associées de l'unesco et le département
accompagne les actions de tous les
collèges de l'île et quand ce collège de
saint paul antoine soubou ben nous fait
la proposition de l'accompagner dans
cette ce beau projet on peut être que
satisfait nous avons apporté une aide
aussi financière au projet barre des
jeunes collégiens qui vont aller vers le
népal vers le longtemps et ça ça aussi
c'est un beau projet qui s'inscrit dans
la promotion des jeunes collégiens
le collège antoine soubou à saint paul
est le premier de lille à intégrer ce
réseau
[Musique]